[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain an american science
fiction comedy film called sleeper
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
[Music]
in the futuristic world of 2173
scientists find a pod in the middle of
the woods that has a human inside of it
the current cruel government doesn't
allow experiments outside its agenda but
a group of scientists decides to open
the pod illegally after taking off the
aluminum foil from the person's face
they reveal a young man who has been in
cryosleep for over 200 years his name is
miles monroe a jazz musician and owner
of a health food store in new york city
in 1973 200 years ago he walked into a
hospital for a routine operation but it
went horribly wrong and ended up with
him being trapped inside a pod for two
decades somehow miles is still wearing
his glasses from years ago after the
revival but the doctors do not question
it he has difficulty standing which is
expected since he hasn't been on his
feet for a long time but he surprises
the scientists by learning to walk
backwards right after being revived
since the government is strictly against
opening the pod if the guard catches
them they will be punished in the new
era criminals are punished with a brain
simplification process they are put into
a machine and turned into a vegetable
the scientist duo has to quickly get him
out of the facility however with miles
eating gloves and walking around like a
drunk man it is a difficult task the
guards eventually find them but the
scientists make it seem like miles is
one of them to get out of the situation
the plan works even though miles does
many questionable things in front of the
guards the scientists then get him
inside the futuristic balloon-like
vessel and bring him to their secret
hideout a few days later miles relearns
to walk converse and eat but he still
doesn't know he's in the future when the
scientists relay the news to him the man
freaks out everyone he knows has been
dead for over a hundred years but he is
the most worried about his house rent
which has been due for two thousand
months when miles shows interest in
returning home he is told about the
harsh world of 2173
a decade ago the world was at a nuclear
war that caused destruction mankind had
never seen millions of people died and
billions were injured cities and
countries were destroyed and a single
government took over the entire world
what once used to be new york is now
just an area between two new cities the
district they are in right now is the
southwestern united states the
information is too much for miles to
take the scientists understand this and
ask him to take a two-week rest until he
fully recovers his strength they will
have to stay low because if the
government finds out about his existence
it won't end well for all three of them
miles also finds out that an
anti-government organization called the
underground is slowly making its way up
to kill the dictator and restore peace
in society for the next few days miles
stays at the headquarters getting
accustomed to the new world of
technologies the scientists use him to
find out more about the people of the
past and their way of life one morning
while having breakfast with the
scientists he is introduced to science's
most advanced invention the servant
robots they are capable of communicating
with humans taking orders and doing all
household tasks at exponential speed
miles will be taken to the western land
in a few days when he inquires why it is
revealed that the main reason he was
revived is to be an asset to the
underground he has to help them
overthrow the government since he is the
only member of the dystopian society
without a known biometric identity hence
he is untrackable by guards miles is not
a fan of the idea and insists that he is
not the revolutionary type however he
doesn't get a chance to protest because
seconds later the hideout is surrounded
by guards sent by the government the
scientists quickly ask miles to go to
the western land and take it upon
themselves to stall the guards while he
runs away he gets on a chair chopper
that is supposed to fly him but instead
it hangs him from a tree the guards use
advanced technology to get to him but in
the end miles manages to lose them by
hiding in the back of a van it is filled
with futuristic robots and their spare
parts when the guards check the van he
sits in a corner disguised as one of the
robots the face paint doesn't do a good
job to hide the fact that he is human
but the guards assume he is an ugly
robot which works in his favor
eventually he is delivered to his owner
luna she is a 22nd century poet and
artist who lives a lavish life she
throws extravagant parties every week
and owns everything she wants in life
miles sees the news about an ancient
alien escaping from the lab and figures
out they are talking about him luna
doesn't really like his face and decides
to get it exchanged next week for now he
is asked to cook a meal for her guests
who will be here any minute back in 1973
miles was a decent cook but the new
ingredients of the future confuse him he
creates a brown explosion of pudding
that keeps on spreading on its own he
also receives the overcoats from the
guest and accidentally burns them in the
debris disposal pod while the guests
enjoy themselves the pudding grows in
size and has to be beaten to death to be
stopped then luna presents everyone with
a silver ball which is a new way of
getting high touching the ball is like
taking recreational pills miles is asked
to pass the ball to everyone which in
turn causes him to get high eventually
he starts fighting for the ball and
hugging a guest but since no one is in
their right mind they do not think much
of it luna and one of her guests get
into the orgasmatron a device that is
used to get intimate without having to
do all the work they come out a few
seconds later more relaxed than ever a
week later luna takes miles to the
nearest robot repair center to get his
head exchanged with a prettier one a
nervous miles is placed on a platform
and is seconds away from being killed
eventually he gives up the act and runs
away revealing that he is the wanted
alien the guards immediately follow him
but he gets away from them knowing that
he cannot survive the outside world on
his own he asks luna for help but she
refuses to listen to him when she tries
alerting the guards he reluctantly has
to abduct her in the following scene
luna is tied to a tree in the middle of
the woods miles takes off her gag but no
matter how loud she screams no one is
coming to save her miles explains to her
that he is not a criminal and everything
that happened was out of his control he
desperately needs to meet the people of
the underground who luna thinks are
criminals she still doesn't support him
and is eager to run away a while later
she gets hungry and demands miles get
food for her he goes looking for it on a
farm where human-sized food and
vegetables are grown strangely they are
also used to generate power after
struggling to pick the massive
strawberry for a while he returns to
luna with a piece of celery and a giant
banana at night luna calms down after
having a bite of the massive celery she
is accustomed to enjoying lavish
commodities and doesn't see the fault in
the government she pretends to be on
miles side but plans to call the police
the first chance she gets the following
day they take shelter in a stranger's
house pretending that their car broke
down luna goes to the bathroom and calls
the police who ask her to stall the
alien until they get there luna makes
miles wear a spacewalk suit and blows it
so he cannot move when the police arrive
they arrest luna first claiming that she
has been infected by the alien she
realizes that the government rules are a
joke and decides to help miles the
couple jumps into the river and deflates
the space suit that helps them escape
eventually they end up in a cave that
holds an ancient volkswagen that still
works using the vehicle they drive to
the west to meet the underground on the
way the two talk about their childhoods
and bond with each other on reaching the
destination they dump the car into a
lake before making their way to an
abandoned house at night they talk about
the vast change in the way people make
love in the past and the present luna
suggests they get inside the orgasmatron
but miles is a fan of more traditional
methods before they agree on what they
should do next the guards arrive and
arrest miles luna saves herself by
hiding inside a secret compartment in
the wall miles is taken to a
reassimilation lab where his memory will
be erased to turn him into an obedient
citizen of the regular modern society
the process of brainwashing begins by
making him think he is miss usa
2173 he is made to go against a bunch of
models and is also given a crowning
ceremony after that his sense of
identity is slowly stolen by making him
go through several tests by the end of
the week he turns into a complete modern
man who could die and kill to protect
the government's ideologies meanwhile
luna has been living in the wild for the
past week she hunts and gathers nuts for
food something she wouldn't have dreamt
of doing in her former way of life one
day while wandering through the woods a
man kidnaps her he is the leader of the
rebellious group named erno he brings
her to his camp where several rebels
like him are plotting ways to dethrone
the current dictator with them luna
learns a lot about survival and the
drawbacks of the government one day
miles walks into his room to see luna
waiting for him she has come to rescue
him but miles doesn't remember her at
all alongside her the people of the
underground have also hidden in the room
they forcefully abduct him and bring him
to the underground camp erno thinks
there is still a way to bring miles back
to his normal self by making him relive
his trauma for that they act like people
from the 19th century to make him
remember his childhood but even after
reciting an entire script of what a
typical family would say in the 90s
miles doesn't remember anything suddenly
he falls unconscious and stays like that
for a few days when he finally wakes up
he is back to his normal self luna tells
him how wonderful erno and his people
have been to her which makes miles
jealous to distract her from the leader
miles suggests they quickly attack the
dictator and fulfill their purpose they
pose as doctors of the national lab and
sneak into the building the duo is
extremely nervous which causes frequent
arguments between them but they somehow
managed to stay unnoticed miles puts his
life in danger to steal two lab coats
while dangling from a window the main
group of scientists believes miles is
the special doctor who has been recently
appointed to the facility for a specific
task they are taken to a room where they
are told what their job is it turns out
that one year ago the dictator died in
an explosion caused by protesters the
only part of him that survived was his
nose since bioengineering has developed
exponentially over the years they plan
to create an entire human out of the
nose using its cells the doctors believe
miles is the man hired to do the job
this makes the task easier for the duo
because they no longer have to kill the
dictator and only have to destroy the
nose the two sneak into the lab but find
out they are being watched by the other
doctors waiting to see the miracle
happen miles and luna know nothing about
cells and start bluffing nonsense the
others soon realize they are trying to
steal the nose and chase them but before
getting caught miles takes the nose
hostage and runs away outside he throws
it under a bulldozer ending the
dictator's life once and for all in the
end miles and luna are together ready to
return to the camp luna thinks aerno
will be a great political leader but
miles doesn't feel the same at this rate
they will be stealing erno's nose next
month because all political leaders are
horrible he asks luna to forget about
this and focus on him the movie ends as
the two share a kiss
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching